35 oh why so yeah i don't know i guess
cause i've been
so into it you know ever since i started
yeah you know like 2012 right yeah
on vine yeah and the first video you do
goes viral
crazy what yeah dude how is that
predestination i don't know
and you know when it happened i was just
like
wait a minute like this is really
happening and my friend was like
you might just keep going now yeah and
i'm saying so i just stayed consistent i
just kept going and you know started
building that
you know that fan base you know so it's
just been
going ever since man so i all started
with the atl talk
atl talk bro let him know what was it
let's look at the
president i was talking about you know
what i'm saying somebody getting into a
fight
you know and i was telling about a dude
you know what i'm saying he running into
a fight but him
being scared he's not one of you know
what i'm saying fight
anybody and it was like this atlanta
talk atlanta slaying type of thing you
know and and then in the south atlanta
slaying
time you know what's going on with
shouting
you know something like that but it was
a atlanta talk video and it went viral
man
and you know it was a good thing it had
to be a good sign
yeah and it was like you know god was
like this is it man this this is where
you're going to find your purpose at
yeah you know once i found that purpose
man it was it was everything man
and that was were you just like in your
living room like this was not a big
production i was in a room yeah
yeah i was in my room like literally in
my room and
it just sparked my mind i said i'm gonna
do this boom when i did it and
posted it and maybe like 10 minutes
later my phone was just
i was like wait a minute yeah yeah what
is this yeah it was crazy
it was crazy like some app my friend
tells me about and now i'm like blowing
up on it instantly
yeah and as i was being consistent on
vine you know my fan base was building
up man and i was just like okay
wow um i may be up to something you know
but
like at that time though i wasn't taken
as serious
only because i was in college and i was
playing sports yeah football right
wide receiver yeah i played receiver
edge um i was at georgia state matter of
fact at the time
moorhead though twice i mean not twice
twice you gave it a shot i did it two
years
and morehead and then i transferred um
to georgia state and finished up
mm-hmm so once i got to georgia state
that's when i like
really got back on to it you know what
i'm saying in 2015 once i graduated
okay i really start back doing it
because you know in between once i was
doing football i wasn't
as focused on the social media you know
what i'm saying like i wanted to be
you know because of sports so if you
think you're going to the league did you
get it i didn't
i thought i was going to the league i
thought i was going to the nfl that's
why i was like you know i ain't worried
about no social media i'm going to nfl
so you know i want to tell you this here
i just knew that atlanta falcons was
going to sign me
and then no but the atlanta panthers
you got the the georgia state panthers
yeah it's a good consolation
yeah well i was wondering what was the
second vine so you probably post the
first one you're like oh i'm a i'm a
prodigy and then did the second one bomb
i don't know if it i can't even remember
oh okay
you you delete the the losses i do yeah
yeah yeah
yeah i do delete the losses um i don't
remember what my second video was
um i'm pretty sure i kept it up there
just because you know what i'm saying
at that time because in the beginning
stages it's like you're just trying to
put stuff out there you're just really
trying to find yourself
yeah so you don't know what the people
like just yet you just really got to be
consistent
at doing something then you go like okay
you might did
been done like 10 videos and then you
like really say okay they like these
what the what gets response do so now i
got to start doing more of this
gotcha that's when i like you know found
that niche with that so
thanks for watching hot breath the verse
if you want to support the show
go join our patreon but if you don't
like supporting a comic on the hustle
at least click the watch more videos to
keep us alive
in the algorithm